[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEX BAIN: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Alex Bain.
I'm the head of marketing
analytics at Nest.
I'm here with Jesse Nichols,
the head of growth at Nest.
And today, we'll be
talking about how
Nest uses Google Cloud and
Tableau to drive its business.
You can ask questions anytime
on the platform, where
we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
Let's get started.
JESSE NICHOLS: Great.
So first of all, since
Alex is a marketer,
and I run growth primarily
from the standpoint of growth
analytics experimentation,
this presentation
will be how we drive the
business through that lens.
We use Google Analytics to drive
a huge portion of our marketing
analysis, and since
we use Analytics 360,
we also leverage
the integration that
sends all of your
website analytics data
into Google BigQuery, of
course, within the cloud.
So to begin, we'll
talk, first, about why
you would use Tableau
versus just using
Google Analytics interface
to do marketing analytics,
or how you could get
extra insights from that.
Then we'll talk
more about why you
would connect through BigQuery
versus the Google Analytics
API, which Tableau also has
a native integration with.
And finally, we'll end
with some tips and tricks
to get you off to the races.
ALEX BAIN: Perfect.
So let's talk about Tableau
versus the GA interface.
So both tools are capable
of segmenting users
and visualizing data.
So how do you
decide when you want
to use one versus the other?
So for Google Analytics,
channel reporting
is very quick and easy.
If you would just want
to understand sessions
from a specific
channel like display,
you can get that
very fast in GA.
Additionally, AdWords,
so shopping ads,
YouTube DoubleClick,
search console data--
a handful of these
dimensions and metrics
simply aren't available
through the API,
and GA is a great
resource in those cases.
And then, finally, simple
answers to simple questions--
so sometimes you
just need to grab
one metric, a one-metric
answer to a question,
and no reason to go
beyond GA in those cases.
So channel reporting--
for example,
sometimes you get a request
about a specific flighted
campaign and how it performed.
It's just easier to get that
in GA if it's a click away,
and you can bookmark that, send
it out to stakeholders as well.
So then when do you use Tableau?
So if you have multiple
data sources-- for example,
you can flow in the
product hierarchy.
So if you want to group a
number of SKUs a certain way,
very easy to create
that reference table
and change it
dynamically as needed,
as new products
come out, and have
Tableau sort of pointed there
and grouping data that way.
So pre-click marketing data--
anything you're doing offline--
for example, you can create
that as another data source
that you would fold in
alongside all of the GA data
that you have flowing in.
Custom dashboards--
so dashboards
are great for tracking campaign
or channel performance,
and marketers love
pretty dashboards,
which Tableau makes
it very easy to build.
So if you want to
create multiple views
of multiple metrics
all in one place,
very easy to do that in Tableau.
And then, finally,
performance versus goals,
so if you establish goals at
the beginning of the year,
and you have those
documented somewhere--
and you see that
in the visual here,
where you have kind of gray
bars referencing the goals--
then you can flow in the
actuals through BigQuery
into Tableau each
week that compares
how you did against your goals.
Very, very helpful as a kind
of ongoing reference in,
say, like a weekly
stakeholder meeting.
JESSE NICHOLS: Exactly.
And similarly, when you're
doing site analysis or growth
optimization analysis,
Google Analytics
is a fantastic tool for just
digging around and exploring
the data.
I mean, first and
foremost, when someone
is asking a straightforward
question, a single answer
question, it's just way easier
to go through the interface
and find it in
the canned report.
So if someone's asking,
how did this one URL
do from a temporary
campaign we just launched,
or what's the percent
of mobile traffic,
or what's the
percent of EU traffic
from this specific country,
a lot of that analysis--
it's a single answer.
Not going to have
to go get it again.
Find it in GA, give
it, and move on.
Again, even when the
data consumer is myself,
it's often a lot easier to
start an exploratory analysis
from within Google Analytics.
There was a recent
issue where I was
trying to find if there were
any browser versions affected
by a site update,
technology update,
and it was just easier to
dig through the interface,
find out what, if
anything, was at risk,
and give an answer to that.
Finally, the reason that I would
use Google Analytics as opposed
to Tableau for analysis is
this kind of segmentation tool
that GA provides, where it's
basically a WYSIWYG Query
Builder, and this
concept's going
to come back in full force
when we talk about BigQuery.
But this tool that you see
in the screenshot there
allows you to kind
of functionally
put together the rudimentary
basics of a query
and get a single
answer, a single metric
to a single question.
Even if you don't
save that segment,
it's a pretty handy tool.
But it's got its limits.
Now in Tableau, I totally agree.
Fully custom
dashboards-- you just
can't go wrong with what
you can do with Tableau.
I mean you can go plenty wrong,
but usually, the handcuffs
are off to a large
degree in what you're
trying to design and build.
The GA dashboards
are quite limited.
They're quite constricting.
But with Tableau, you've
got design colors.
You're really putting
together a full dashboard.
So I love that I can have my
marketers-- give my marketers
something that they can
self-serve with and anticipate
their needs.
And then there's a handful
of features, again,
that you can do inside
the GA interface--
just a lot easier when
you're in Tableau,
such as providing filters
to limit the amount of data
or change the data that's
someone seeing within
a dashboard, and even
controlling exactly which
filters you get, which filters
you're-- which dimensions
you're filtering on.
So that kind of stuff, again,
way better through Tableau.
And then, finally, again,
these are technologies
that we leverage in
great detail when
we start to flow
in BigQuery data,
but even just your
normal Tableau interface
is far better at slicing your
data by a certain dimension
or helping you differentiate
between line or bar charts
through coloring and other
classic data vis techniques.
So I think that it's
very situational,
but Tableau gives us a
lot more flexibility when
we're trying to share out data.
OK, so once you've kind of got
a sense of when you would use
Tableau over GA, it begs
the question of, well,
why wouldn't you just be using
the Google Analytics API, which
is already within Tableau?
What's the extra benefit
you get through BigQuery?
ALEX BAIN: Sure.
So both are just a click away.
As you can see,
individuals here,
as you're setting
up a new Tableau
file-- very easy to pull in
GA directly through that API
or BigQuery directly
through that API.
But if you go the
GA route, and you're
working with a relatively
large data set,
you can be waiting a long time.
So BigQuery comes
back about as fast
as the cloud can get it to you.
So for example, if you're
looking at multi-year data
sets, and you're trying to
understand seasonality trends,
you're going to get into
sample data on the--
if you're using
the GA interface,
and you won't know
as you're looking
at noise if that is
due to seasonality
or if that is due to sampling.
So the BigQuery interface or
API helps a bunch in that case.
JESSE NICHOLS: Yeah, I mean I
don't know how many times I've
been asked about some
very small metric that
is very important,
very business critical,
but it's like a
needle in a haystack.
And even with robust sampling,
you just don't even--
data's almost not usable
at a certain level,
and certainly as
you go back in time.
So you know I've been
involved in a lot of analysis
projects, where precision
is just necessary.
And BigQuery, you just have no
reason to give up precision.
ALEX BAIN: Yeah.
Jesse.
JESSE NICHOLS: So you know,
I think, as an analyst,
certainly as someone
who's spent probably
80%, 90% of my time
in analytics tools,
having unlimited control
over the segmentation you're
doing within the data
is incredibly powerful.
And it's also
incredibly frustrating
when you know the
answer is in the data,
and you just can't get to it.
So the limit here is that
within Tableau's GA connection,
you are limited, basically,
to GA's segment builder.
You have to use the
segmentation builder
that I showed before
in GA's interface
before you port it
over to Tableau.
And there are a whole bunch
of things that you just
can't build in that thing that
just feel just out of reach.
Specifically, when
you have, let's say,
a pretty standardized
event naming structure--
the same event could fire
from multiple pages--
you can't really tie
those two things together
in the GA segment builder.
But as an e-commerce shop,
just knowing certain product
combinations being
purchased together, again,
just one of the limits of
the GA segment builder.
You can't build these kind
of multi-product combinations
or adding multiple products
to your cart over one journey.
You can really only analyze
one product at a time,
so it's kind of a showstopper
for a company like Nest.
But really, pretty much
any hit level logic,
you're constrained from doing
in the GA segment builder,
while, in BigQuery, you
can see I shamefully
used legacy SQL to flag segments
with pretty much any segment
logic that I want.
And the idea is that that logic
that you're putting in there
is all hit level, and if you
need to reconcile segments that
have-- sessions that have
multiple hits within one
session, then you just
stack a bunch of these,
and use and/or
rules, just like you
would in the segment builder
in some sort of outer query,
and boom.
You have any segment
you could want to build.
You can investigate any set
of users that you'd want.
It was really a freeing
moment, as an analyst, when
I finally put all these
pieces together and was
like, oh, OK, yeah, game on.
It was a nice moment, so I
strongly encourage digging
into this if you haven't used
the GA data in BigQuery before.
The thing that you can
stack on from there,
however, is, I think, an order
of magnitude more powerful.
So within-- again,
as an analyst,
you're trying to find
business insights that
are relative to
their total scale
or relative to the context of
the greater business, which
is really about a
calculated metric.
A flat standard metric--
it's kind of like, is that a
number that's-- is that a big
number?
Is it a large
percent of our sales?
And so these calculated
metrics are critical.
They're just absolutely
vital to understanding--
these ratios are
vital to understanding
the health of the business
or the health of some metric
you're pursuing.
And the constraint with
both GA's segment builder
and the Tableau
connection to GA is
that you can segment
some session metric,
and then you can segment
some other session metric.
But because these are
different segments,
the numbers have no
relationship to each other.
You can't just divide
one on top of another
to create a new
calculated metric,
because, again, that
segment is applied
to all data in the structure.
And you're just
kind of hamstrung,
and you got to do a lot of
work to torture that out
of the tool, and
then recombine it.
It's just a real pain.
But when you do this
work within BigQuery,
like I showed you before,
your segments-- you can kind
of capture however you want.
And you bubble them
up as a standard kind
of pre-calced metric.
And then you've got
yourself a numerator
and denominator and, again,
unlimited total control.
If you were trying to
seat yourself to GA,
you'd have to have all this
foresight to set a goal,
and you only get a
certain number of goals.
Even if you set a
goal, it can only
be applied in the future
and not retroactively.
This unlocks all of it.
You just kind of--
the stress is gone.
ALEX BAIN: Maybe we
should do the example
of shoppers on nest.com.
That was a good insight you had.
JESSE NICHOLS: Yeah,
that was another kind
of game-changing
moment in the way
that we did analysis and looked
for growth opportunities.
You know, nest.com-- you can
do all sorts of things there.
You can manage your--
control your devices.
You can get support.
You can work with pro partners.
So only a limited segment of
our total visit population
are these shoppers.
And, in fact, if you
had a big support issue,
you'd have a burst in
traffic and a decline
in conversion rate, when,
really, your shopper metric
was totally unaffected.
And so we really
had to figure out
a way to not only pull those
shoppers out as a segment,
but then, also, that needed to
become the de facto denominator
in all of our calculations.
And anything you
stack on top of it
kind of had to take
that as a given.
So we defined find a
shopper and, again, started
building metrics on top of it.
How many shoppers were--
what percent of
shoppers were going
through this specific flow?
What percent of shoppers were
buying a mixed transaction
with more than one piece
of core hardware in it?
And again, these calcs had just
been out of our reach before.
So this was a real
game changer using
BigQuery to mash
all this together
and Tableau to visualize.
And then, finally, just
to ice this cake a bit,
I love to take the
segmented metrics
that I've built in BigQuery
and turn them into dimensions
using a case statement.
And I think you can probably--
you could use these case
statements in either
Tableau or BigQuery,
but it is still the fundamental
work, the groundwork
that you've laid
that enables this.
And what this is
referring to is,
usually, you're stuck
with the dimensions
that you've had to do
your kind of slices
of comparisons-- country,
device category, channel,
things like that.
But really, when
you want to know
the impact of using a thing
versus not using a thing,
if you want to be
able to compare
that fluidly in
Tableau, you need
to be able to treat
that as a dimension.
And so using a case statement,
you take these underlying rules
that you've built,
and you simply
say, OK, well if they did this
thing, you name them one thing.
If they didn't do it, you
name them something else.
And boom, you can do this
concept that, at least at Nest,
we refer to by slicing
by or coloring by,
to take all of the metrics
you've built below,
all the calculated metrics,
and simply chop them
by the dimension
you just outlined.
So in this false
example, if we had a way
to infer what someone's
dietary preference was based
on some series of
actions they could take,
we can build those as metrics
that would flag those sessions.
And then you use case
statements to just kind
of separate each
group into each other.
And then all of the
conversion rate metrics,
segmentation traffic
metrics, everything
you kind of make
beneath that can now
be sliced by this new
magical inference dimension
that you've pulled out of.
So pretty great stuff, and,
again, huge supercharge
to the analysis we've done.
ALEX BAIN: Stakeholders
feel very empowered when
they can play around
with the interface
to make it reflect
what they want to see.
It also is the case, then, that
if it all lives in one vis,
that if you need to
make formatting changes
or incorporate new
data sources later on,
you don't have to
do that times five.
If you've got that built into
the slice by or color by,
it's all in one place.
JESSE NICHOLS: Yeah,
and, again, this
isn't really the
same thing as just
using grouping functionality
on normal GA data.
You actually need that data
to come through BigQuery
to be where you're building
metrics off of the segments
in the first place.
And then once you've
done that, you
can really transform
your utility with this.
Well, hopefully,
we can convince you
at least a little bit
that using BigQuery
can give you far more power
when looking for marketing
and growth opportunities.
Now we'll share a
few tips and tricks
on how we use traditional
Tableau capabilities layered
on top of this stuff
that we've unlocked
with BigQuery to,
again, really power
up our marketing and
vis opportunities.
ALEX BAIN: So when you're
evaluating marketing
performance, it's very
straightforward to divide
revenue and cost, and call that
RoAS, or Return on Ad Spend.
The challenge is if
you're selling something
that itself has cost, a cost
of goods sold, then by the time
you've pulled that
out, what you thought
was break-even is actually
quite unprofitable.
So what you really want to do
is look at margin or profit
divided by cost.
So if you have the
concept for a given,
say, hardware product of what
it costs to make that product,
you can create a reference
table that has the price as well
as the, say, profit per unit.
And you can evaluate
what you're spending
on marketing relative
to the profit
that you're bringing
into the company,
and see if your marketing
is truly paying for itself.
When it is, it's very easy
to secure additional budget.
JESSE NICHOLS: Yeah, and
it's a lot nicer this way
than to ask your
finance team if you
can put your margin into
a custom metric that
flows over the open web.
So it's an even kind of
upgrade, even from, I think,
what normal GA
capabilities would provide.
ALEX BAIN: So another example--
agencies can keep
their secret sauce.
So if your agency is
going out and negotiating
preferential costs with
individual platforms,
they may not want to share that,
or it might be in the contract
that it can't be shared.
So they could create, for
example, an aggregated view
of their cost, where it's
aggregated at a level
that it's consistent
with their contract.
They could put
that, for example,
into Google Sheets, which
could be pointed to Tableau
as an additional data source.
So you can look at traffic,
conversion, et cetera,
and you can do it in
the context of the cost
that the agency is
reporting to you.
So it makes it easy
to be compliant.
Additionally, orders
versus shipments--
so it might be
the case that what
you're seeing in GA is orders,
but if you were actually
shipping something,
if you had preorders,
if you had a backlog,
if there's just
some sort of delay
with a supplier,
there can be a gap between
orders and shipments,
and Tableau helps you to blend
that data in and visualize
the difference.
It can be very handy, especially
at peak times of the year.
Parameterizing dimensions--
sounds fancy, because it is.
So it's a classic
Tableau feature.
It becomes even more
powerful if you have segments
that you're working with.
So you can create
an if-then statement
that powers a
parameter and makes
it easier for data consumers
to filter and control
the dashboard.
So what you see here
is the slice by example
we were talking about before.
So what you would do is you
would create a calculated field
in Tableau called, say,
Slice By, that then
points at the output
of a parameter.
So that allows you
to quickly toggle
a dashboard between looking
at everything by country
versus looking at
everything by device.
It can be really handy when
you're talking about conversion
rates, for example.
You might see a very
different conversion rate
on mobile versus tablet versus
desktop, and the most common
we have is to look at-- to jump
in and out of, say, countries
and regions.
JESSE NICHOLS: Yeah.
Yeah, I mean this was
also-- as we started
to do more of these kind
of metrics as dimensions
concept, where you're
taking your underlying KPIs,
the core segment of the traffic,
a couple of your core metrics,
and you're building
all the visualizations
you want from that.
And then you use this parameter
concept to start splitting
by all of the major
metrics as dimensions
that you've built up.
Again, finding opportunities
is far more fluid, far more
natural, and also,
as you make changes
to some of these
things, if you're
trying to analyze the
improvement to a conversion
rate after having to watch a
video or a number of videos
or certain videos or engaging
with certain features
on your site, it's a
very painful process
of exploration in GA.
But once they're
parameters in Tableau,
it's just a simple matter of
flipping through and looking
for what strikes you that day.
ALEX BAIN: It's also, you can
build the view around whatever
the goals are for
the business so that,
as opposed to exposing
kind of everything that
is possible to look at, you
narrow the stakeholder's
field of view to
only the things that
are the goals for the year.
So if they're working
on conversion rate,
you'd be looking at that just
by country and device as opposed
to any other sort of
possible dimension
that you could want
to get crazy with.
JESSE NICHOLS: Cool.
And finally, when using
BigQuery with Tableau,
again, I assume this is
a bit of a choice you're
making with most of the times
you're going to use these two
tools interact.
But you need to
decide whether you
want a pre-aggregated table
or something closer to like
a visit or session-level table.
And really, this is the
tension choice between,
do you want speed, or
do you want flexibility?
Or in my case, are you
complacent with laziness,
or do you really demand
complexity from the work
that you're about to do?
And really, for
pre-aggregated tables,
I think the single
defining factor that's
going to make it the
most obvious choice
is length of time and
complexity of underlying query.
If you've got a
fairly complex query,
and you're trying to do analysis
over six, 12, 24, 36 months,
it's best, if possible,
to simplify it
into a pre-aggregated table, and
it'll be just moving lightning
fast without any pause.
So a lot easier to do
historical analysis.
If it's a relatively
simple function,
you just keep sending
it to the same table,
and it's kind of
rolling on its own.
Visit-level tables--
I tend to think
of those more as an analyst
tool than a sharable dashboard.
They tend to move a lot slower
if you have a lot of data,
and they're way more
flexible, so you
don't need to think about
every aggregation you're
going to do up front.
A classic example
is something where
there are many possible
combinations of users that you
would want to
explore, and you don't
want to have to pre-aggregate
every possible one beforehand.
So one of the cooler projects
we've done based on this
technology, having a visit-level
table in BigQuery powering
through--
visualized through Tableau,
was a product-level funnel,
starting from the earliest point
in the shopping flow, where
you can engage with
that product, which
is different for each
product, and then
showing the fall-off as you
went through to conversion.
And a single person
could and often did
engage with multiple product
funnels in a single visit.
So you couldn't possibly have
had an outer table that really
kind of summed all that up
without having just hundreds
of rows or hundreds
of lines of SQL code.
And so with an inner
query and a little work
in Tableau, we got to
the answers we needed,
and it was just
phenomenally insightful.
Not something I share with the
general public data consumers
at Nest, but it was
super helpful for us
growth analysts looking for
product-level opportunities.
And to wrap things
up, here is just
my go-to list of the dimensions
as they appear in BigQuery.
They might seem a little
random or ad hoc to you guys,
but out of the
200-plus dimensions
that I use in
BigQuery for GA data,
this represents 90% of them.
And I get really, really
far out of just this stuff.
So again, I can't encourage
you enough to check out
that integration, if
you haven't already.
It's an order of magnitude
difference in the powers
you get as an analyst.
ALEX BAIN: So stay
tuned for live Q&A.
We'll be back in
less than a minute.
Welcome back.
So we've got some Q&A
we'll be going through now.
We've got some good questions.
So first question-- how do
you account for discrepancies
between what you see
in Google Analytics
and what you get from BigQuery?
So great question.
It does come up
from time to time.
I can think of two sort of
classic examples of where
you'd see this.
So one would be if you are
looking at a long time series--
for example, if you wanted
to evaluate the last three
black Fridays that you'd
had some sort of campaign
or promotion around.
You're pulling in
three years of data.
With Google Analytics,
you'd get into sampling, so
at a week level, you
would start to see
discrepancies between what
were the actual data--
the actual, say,
visits in BigQuery
versus the sampled
view of that from GA.
So sampling could
be one reason why
you would have a discrepancy.
Another kind of classic reason
might be that you have actually
structured the BigQuery
segment, for example,
that you're treating as kind of
the source of truth for, say,
sessions-- and maybe the
shopper example is a good one--
to exclude support traffic or
to exclude traffic to forums.
So it's intended to
leave certain things out,
whereas GA might be
bringing in more raw data.
So in that case, the
BigQuery was intended
to be the source of truth.
And it's often a purposeful way.
JESSE NICHOLS: Yeah,
that was actually
something I got a lot over the--
when I first introduced shopper
traffic as a metric
is not very easily
or at all discoverable within
Google Analytics, because you
had to do some segmentation
magic, much of which
was only available through
what I was doing in BigQuery.
And so I had to kind of retrain
a lot of our data consumers
as to what the
source of truth was
for certain types of questions.
And once it kind of
became the nomenclature,
people accepted, oh,
the shopper thing
is a thing we get from Tableau.
And people went to the GA
interface less and less,
if that's not a question
that they felt they
could get the answer there.
ALEX BAIN: Yes.
So let's see.
So the next question--
what have been some of the most
insightful analysis projects
using Tableau and BigQuery?
So a great question.
So I think GA, by
default, ends up
doing a lot of last click
attribution when you're looking
at marketing, so you'll get
a lot of credit for search
and less so for display--
typically, display advertising.
What we started doing was to
fold in aggregated data out
of DoubleClick, and we
had some rules set up
around how to attribute revenue
back to display advertising.
So we had that aggregated
and calculated,
and then we would
kind of compare
that to channel level
traffic and activity that we
were seeing in GA.
You could map one
against the other
to say, OK, how is our
marketing doing holistically
or at a channel level?
And it gave us the freedom
to invest more actively
in display advertising.
JESSE NICHOLS: Yeah.
Yeah, there's also one-- other
than the funnel part, Funnel 1,
which was one of my earliest
proud sculptures I built,
was that I worked with
a couple other analysts
to form kind of a visitor
table or visitor ID table
that would give us a sense of
who is a likely customer, even
if they weren't logged in.
We don't necessarily track any
customer identification level
stuff in our GA
instance, particularly,
but we do have a lot of
signals that they're customer,
namely that we know if
they bought something
from in a store, we can flag
that Google Analytics visitor
ID as a customer.
If they came from an email
that only went to customers,
we know that as well.
And so we kind of
built this rough table
that gave us an approximation
of who our known customers were.
And we could start to segment
by that data, just customer
versus non-customer traffic.
And also, incredibly
insightful, again,
when you have no other way,
especially other than maybe
whether they're logged in or not
as to whether that person was
a customer, and huge
growth opportunities
were found through that.
ALEX BAIN: Yeah.
Let's see.
Next question-- can you get
real-time Google Analytics data
through BigQuery?
JESSE NICHOLS: Much
to Alex's disbelief,
you actually can get it.
ALEX BAIN: I didn't know.
JESSE NICHOLS: And I think it
was launched sometime around
last year.
Yeah, with real time, it was one
of the kind of last remaining
vestiges and benefits of going
through the Google Analytics
interface.
But getting it into
the BigQuery data set,
and then piping
it over to Tableau
has been really phenomenal
for our dev teams who
do a lot of uptime monitoring,
just kind of like day
to day check in.
They've obviously got lots
of other uptime tools,
but they'll blend those together
and watch QPS or, rather,
more QPM, queries per minute,
site traffic per minute,
and just general volume.
We also use it
around launch dates,
where we're pulling in
lots of real-time data--
ALEX BAIN: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
JESSE NICHOLS: --as
fresh as possible.
And being about 15
minutes fresh gives us
the impact of individual
press releases
or individual cycles
that we put out there.
And yeah, real-time
data through BigQuery
has been just lightning
hot when it's needed.
ALEX BAIN: So let's see.
Next question-- what's the
advantage of using Tableau
over Google's data vis product?
JESSE NICHOLS: Yeah,
I think they're
talking about Google
Data Studio, which
I've had a lot of
experience with as well.
Both are phenomenal products.
Both have a connection
to BigQuery.
Tableau has a few
advantages when
you're doing some of the
more complex dashboard
development or the
analysis that we
talk a lot about, the
parameterizing dimensions
and slice by and some
instances of color by.
You just have more control.
Google's Data Studio--
I love it that you don't--
you have a single canvas,
and you're kind of painting
the elements of the dashboard
on there.
So you don't need the complexity
of, like, one sheet per graph,
like you need with Tableau.
You can just kind of work
from one or two canvas spaces
and just mix and
match as you need.
So they're also just the
same as Tableau and GA,
kind of situational.
But both have a
BigQuery connection,
so I've used them both.
ALEX BAIN: Terrific.
Well, that's all for today.
Please tune in next Tuesday
for the next Cloud OnAir.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]